everyone this is kevin from the chess
website comm and today we are in bonus
chest time after 11 rounds in the 2017
US Chess Championships we have a tie at
the top you Wesley so in alexandra chuck
and today we will be playing a
tiebreaker today they have two games
each side will get the white side once
and they have 25 minutes on their clocks
there's no incremental move in this
position which means you know a lot of
times in chess after movie at 15 seconds
we get 30 seconds additional time not so
the case in this tiebreaker 25 minutes
after that's gone you will lose if we
have a tie for that we get into an
Armageddon sudden death match which is
kind of crazy not my favorite but very
very exciting way to end so we'll go
ahead and get started
Wesley so does have the white pieces in
game 1 and starts with pawn to c4 which
is met by pawn to e6 and then Knight to
c3 a lot of times we see kind of a
Queen's game but a climb line this c4
just immediately gets into d4 and d5 but
you know a lot of times in rapid tile we
see just crazy openings that we don't
typically see in a longer game and
that's what we get from nice to see 3
Knight f6 pawn to e4 so this is the
floor McInnis in the English opening
interesting that Alex decided to go for
this black doesn't typically fare well
if you look at the database for you know
highest level play in this opening black
very rarely wins and white has a huge
advantage in the wind calm so we will
continue upon down here to d5 trying to
break at the center pawn takes on d5
recaptured them pawn up here to e5
attacking the knight and the knight
comes down here at the e-force nice
little outpost move white can kick it
off if he wants to or he could just play
up here you know pawn to d4 just
solidified not worry about the knight
right now because if there is an
exchange you could recapture with this
pawn here and that's going to be
completely fine he would control the
center of the board right there
continues normal development with Knight
to f3 Bishop down here to f5 and then
Bishop to e2 and Wesley so actually
played this opening against knock'em or
not too long ago and in that game he
played pawn to
or and if you were kind of watching the
coverage live they went over this Wesley
so decided that probably Alex had looked
at that specific game knowing that he
got into the floor McInnis opening on
his own so he's promoting that Wesley so
decided to change it up a little bit
he's very familiar with its opening
having played himself and decides to go
and play Bishop e2 first Bishop to e7
and then castle on the King said he had
a few options some of the options that
we were looking at during the live
coverage was Queen to b3 this does
attack both the pawn here on d5 with
both the knight and the Queen attacking
it also attacking this square here on b7
since lives where Bishop has come out no
longer defending that Square that for
white decides to castle on the King side
then we have castle on the King side for
black as well and then Queen to b3
attacking this square it and this is
where Alex started to take a lot of time
thinking remember you only have about 25
minutes he thought for almost nine
minutes and played Knight here to c6 he
recognizes that he he castle on the King
side which makes a lot of sense for King
side safety but he did kind of lead this
pawn exposed here in d5 after Queen to
b3 decided to somewhat just give that up
and continue with normal development but
spending nine minutes he only has
fifteen minutes remaining on his clock
after only the ninth move here so after
Knight to c6 would you see the knight
take up here on d5 and then Bishop down
here to c5 and he had a couple other
options you know it could have tried
Knight to c5 attacking the Queen Queen
could come up here to c4 Bishop here to
e6 just consolidate a little bit in the
middle of the board Knight takes on e7
taking the bishop Queen takes c7 white
does have the bishop pair here but they
you know black has some counter play
Knight here to e4 Queen to e3 all of a
sudden black can get his rooks involved
into the game I don't think this is
necessarily that bad for black decides
to go and bring his Bishop down here to
a c5 and then Knight down here to e3 and
this is interesting because 93 is
probably the best move that everyone
kind of found for Wesley so and he did
find it this [ __ ]
ship is attacking the pawn here on f2 so
one of the moves that we thought might
be played was pawn to d3 attacking this
knight right here but from here we could
just see Knight 2 f2 and you're not
going to see the rook take is then the
just a bishop recapture that's probably
not good so maybe now pawn pushes to d4
Knight or bishop back here to e6 attack
of the night if we do see an exchange on
board that's probably going to be fine
for black Queen back here to c2 and then
we could see some exchange on board and
then up here to g4 if the bishop takes
that's fine Queen comes down here to d4
check and attacking the bishop as well
if instead bishop takes on c6 you know
we could just take it back right away
with our pawn so either way I think this
was a good very good find for Wesley so
we found this in only about a minute to
play Knight back here to e3 since you
have a central night here on d5 it's
protected by your queen sometimes
bringing it back is not the easiest fine
but you found it correctly recognized
that this Bishop attacking the square
here on f2 a support from the knight was
just a huge you know variation that he
didn't want to have to go down and
calculate a lot and knowing the his
opponent is kind of in a time crunch
right now
he doesn't he wants to continue with his
path of you know I'm finding right now I
have a pawn advantage so let's not go
down any crazy lines let's just force
our opponent to spend a lot of time see
if they can make mistakes continue with
normal chess so Bishop back here to a g6
since was being attacked from the night
here on e3 and then Queen takes on a b7
a could have decided now to play pawn to
d3 since the knight on e3 is you know
stopping some of that threat I think
pawn to d3 makes a lot of sense kicking
the knight back here potentially g5 now
the Queen can take Knight down here to
d4 we could see an exchange in this area
of the board but that does give white
and extra pawn and material if you
wanted to what I think of maybe slightly
better position decides to go ahead and
play Queen - b7 first now Knights down
to d4 would you see the exchange on
board and now pawn to d3 so
slightly different variation that got us
kind of to the same point but now night
over here to c5 which is a little bit
different than if we played it
originally then the night might have
come over here to g5 but nice and c5
attacking the Queen the Queen comes back
down here to b5 and then work over here
to b8 attacking the Queen what so so
retreats the Queen back here to c4 and
then Knight up here to e6 and there's
kind of two options nice to e6 makes
sense even rook over here to e8 seems
pretty good you know Knight to e6 this
protects his bishop here on d4 he's both
protecting it with his knight and his
Queen here on d8 but this also opens up
the door for pawn to c5 this is going to
be a great move later on for Alex if he
can find it it really cements this
bishop here on d4 it's a great little
outpost and it also allows him to get
his queen free and not have to defend of
this bishop put this clean or his night
he could just defend it with his pawn
here on c5 but plays Knight here to e6
which i think is a great move also
allows him to bring that night over to
the key inside the board if you wants to
attack that pawn to f4 so very you know
aggressive way for Wesley so to start to
attack on the King side also preparing
for this pawn to just push forward up
here to f5 now from here we see Alex
played Bishop takes down on b2 I think
this was a huge opportunity it's very
very difficult to find pawn here to c5
but then after pawn pushes forward to f5
so we talked about the Queen no longer
has to worry about defending this so now
the Queen can get involved Queen down
here to g5 this is threatening the night
here on e3 that would be a check and so
you can't really take material but if
you were to take on e6 which I think
would be a mistake then Bishop to e3
King here to h1 Queen takes material
there on a five and then maybe the
Bishop takes Queen baek's down here on
III and this is going to be a fine
position for black did not find the c5
move instead decided to go and play
Bishop down here to be two didn't take
too long
to think about it rook here to be one so
he is you know protecting this material
he does have his rook up here but he
could decide to go ahead and exchange
symmetry off the board Wesley so since
he's up in material Wesley's probably
more inclined to start trading off
material because if he can consolidate
pieces down he's going to have a better
in-game that's kind of what Wesley so is
looking to do Alex really needs to find
a path where he can start to find an
advantage even though he is down in
material Queen down here to d4 and this
is another one of those places where he
probably had a better movie just doesn't
have a lot of time left he is you know
six or seven minutes at this point he
could have played Knight to d4 he does
have a bishop and the Queen both
protecting this he could later on even
play pawn to c5 if he wanted to solidify
this a little bit more but this
threatens the knight coming down here to
e2 so if we were to see rook takes on b2
which makes a lot of sense now rook
takes Bishop takes back on b2 now Knight
down here to e2 check King over here to
h1 and then Queen to h4 is kind of that
great move where it sets up essentially
a draw like we wanted to go down that
path a rook to d1 Knight up here to g3
the pawn can take you kids it's being
been pinned down from the Queen so this
is probably the best fine that black
could have had knowing that Weslaco has
a better position he could have played
that night to d4 great little central
square for this knife and then probably
come out with a drawl here but decide to
play Queen to d4 that's met by the rook
takes now the rook takes and then you
know the rook is being defended by the
Queen so that's part of the reason he
had that there and then Bishop up here
to g4 now I think in this position black
has kind of two moves that he can go
with he could either say you know Wesley
so has a huge attack going on I'm going
to start to gobble up some of the big
material maybe my opponent just has a
pawn advantage at the end and I can
squeeze out a draw I think if you're
going down that path you just go ahead
and take this Queen here on t4 and say
I'm going to take your biggest material
piece
with the bishop here to g4 Wesley so is
threatening pawn up here to f5 with the
fork of the night and the bishop but one
of the moves he actually has is Queen to
a b6 this does a couple things it keeps
the knight being pinned down to the King
that's very important it also protects
the rook here on b2 but it also there's
kind of this you know discovered attack
after pawn to b5 now that we can come up
to b4 it's still protecting this rook
and now let's attacking the Queen and
the bishop once the Queen moves then
this bishops going to fall the night
can't recapture because it's still being
pinned down from this Queen so that
would have been a nice find Alex I think
did make a mistake in this position this
is one of those you know they kind of
asked him about it and said you know
just didn't calculate nearly as long as
you need to just because he didn't have
enough time
he played rook here to b4 and that was
met with the Queen takes now the knight
takes but then pawn to f5 it's the fork
that white was going for now he really
doesn't have to worry about all those
threats the bishop can't fall it's being
protected by the Knights no longer being
pinned down from the Queen
this gets a little dangerous now Knight
down here to f4 and then the great fine
from Wesley so also didn't take him very
long to find it because he's just been a
machine lately and that is Knight down
here to see - and this is one of those
where sometimes it can be very difficult
to have kind of a central knight and
move that backwards
in some way but what this does is it
opens up for this dark square Bishop to
attack the knight this rook is also
attacking the knight it's attacking the
rook also this pawn is still attacking
the bishop right here and so there's
just not a lot of great squares for Alex
to go he's just being under attack for
so many different places
he's almost forced to move his rook
right now because you don't want to lose
you know that major piece going into the
in part of the endgame and so after rook
here to a4 then Bishop takes on f4 can't
even recapture that because the rook is
protecting that now he has to worry
about his bishop over here on g6 and the
pawn comes down here to h5 okay Bishop
comes back here
one it's going to be a discovered attack
after the Night Moves attacking the rook
here on a four bishop comes back here to
h7 now night to e3 as we talked about
the rook does decide to go ahead and
come down here to a to take material but
that's fine because Wesley so finds this
great attack just starts pushing his
pawns and says you know there's just no
real way for you to stop me and you can
see this light square Bishop on h7 it's
kind of trapped because then I hear on
III just doing a great job of
controlling the center of the board with
his Knights maneuvering it around to
exactly the right squares after the pawn
takes a bishop up here to b3 both
attacking the pawn
pinning it to the King and attacking the
rook rook is forced to move come over
here to e2 but all of Wesley's those
pieces are protected so well so pawn to
e6 getting ready to push that forward
rook over here to e8 that's fine let's
push it forward there's no way to really
kind of stop the attack that's going on
right here well Alex would like to take
the pawn this was a discovered attack so
he is forced to move and so he plays
King over here to h8 and then Bishop up
here to g5 protecting this pawn and at
the end of the day there's just no way
to really stop this next move we could
just play rook to f8 you know alex is in
a tough position so he decides to go
ahead and resign this game so that is a
game one we are not going to be looking
at Game two if you want to go look at
that you definitely can it was a longer
game that game did end in a draw so I
was able to make one video decided to go
ahead and make the video on this one
since it was an exciting match in Wesley
so did win this one so at the end the
day Wesley so is the champion ended up
not losing a game at the US Chess
Championship so congratulations to him
finally does have that US Chess
Championship and as we said before came
in as the heavy favorite
he's been the hottest chess player in
the world doesn't seem to be stopped by
anyone so congratulations to him great
chess played throughout the entire
tournament and you know Alex hunter
shook
played an amazing tournament well above
what he's used to play he doesn't even
play that many tournaments and for him
to come in and perform as well as he did
I mean if he won yesterday he would be
in the outright champion but getting
that draw coming in here to a very tough
Challenger and a tiebreaker someone that
you know has probably way more
experience in rapid chest and he does
I thought he played pretty well in Game
two actually played extremely well
Wesley so defended a fierce attack by
Alex with the white pieces at the other
day I was exciting congratulations to
Wesley so thanks everyone for watching
the tournament coverage and I will see
you guys in the next tournament coverage
thanks again